vaccines typically take years to develop
but there's reasons to be hopeful that
we could have a vaccine against the
corona virus pandemic in record time
there are more than 40 vaccine
candidates being developed currently
according to the WHL at a basic level
the evolution of vaccines we've gone
from testing a weakened or killed
version of the virus to injecting a
protein that can fight against the virus
when we think of the SARS outbreak in
2002 2003 it took about 20 months to go
from genetic sequence to that first
patient being dosed in a first clinical
trial leading the pack is moderna
an upstart buzzie biotech that developed
a vaccine candidate that has already
started a clinical trial that is
record-breaking pace in about two months
time so this happened about ten times as
quick how did moderna do it they have a
technology platform called messenger RNA
I talked to the CEO a few weeks ago he
sees this as the evolution of vaccine
development that's its particular geared
for speedy development of vaccines now
moderna just injects genetic
instructions that has your own cells
create copies of the protein the
antibodies that can fight against the
virus on the flip side there are no
approved mRNA vaccines on the market so
this is an unproven technology that will
be tested in real time against the
corona virus there's about six or seven
companies that have put out timelines
for coronavirus vaccines where they're
hoping to start clinical trials in 2020
so those candidates will enter the
clinic in the spring or summer for the
most part and have data coming a few
months after that that initial data will
focus more on safety making sure these
vaccines don't cause side-effects and
they're tolerable in humans additional
studies have to be run that test if it
actually works if getting the vaccine
can prevent infections of the 'quran
virus some of the biggest drug makers in
the industry including Sanofi and
Johnson & Johnson have also jumped in
the mix Johnson Johnson is looking at
starting a clinical trial in November
Sanofi as estimated they can start a
clinical trial in early 2021 so those
are much longer timelines as far as
starting a clinical trial they kind of
envision a tortoise and a hare situation
where they have proven technology
they've done this many times they have
the resources of Big Pharma to pump out
this to a mass market of hundreds of
millions of people if needed
so those approaches are also worth
watching and they're moving as fast as
they can on that front vaccine
development is really expensive and with
infectious diseases it's hard to know
the return on investment for these
companies so there's big funding gap
with vaccine development that's remains
unanswered it's worth considering the
case of Merck one of the biggest drug
makers in the world they have the only
FDA approved Ebola vaccine that took
several years of clinical trials and on
president's scale Merck had to invest
hundreds of millions of dollars to get
this over the finish line and it's
essentially a net loss for the company
financially one group that's really
helped accelerate the pace of vaccine
development is called sepi the Coalition
for epidemic preparedness of innovations
this was started by the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation along with a lot of
other philanthropic support in 2017 it's
backed and funded the progression of
candidates including moderna x' as well
as several other vaccines in the early
stages there's a lot of unknowns
surrounding a corona virus vaccine not
just is it safe and effective but when
we get to that point or if we get to
that point with a vaccine candidate what
happens next how much data will the FDA
require could the FDA offer an emergency
approval
what would pricing and accessibility
look like particularly if a small
biotech like moderna or some of these
other small companies that are
progressing candidates into the clinic
in 2020 if one of those vaccines is
found to be safe and effective how can a
small biotech skill that up to deliver a
vaccine to hundreds of millions of
people it still remains to be seen if
these companies need to run much larger
clinical trials enrolling tens of
thousands of people who will pay for
that how much will it cost and these
companies which are for-profit
pharmaceutical companies can they make
return of investment
that and make a business case for that
or will philanthropic sources like sepi
the Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
have to step up to push some of these
vaccines over the finish line
[Music]